[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks
we might be drunk good to be here sorry
what you're saying oh we're just talking
tarantino there's a video with a woman
uh she's like why the violence why the
violence yeah because i love it because
it's great and it sells tickets you [ __ ]
leave us alone
who cares about we're coming out hard i
guess
you know what's funny they're going to
tarantino the way they go at hockey
why the fighting why the fighting like
if you get it out that person
complaining about it is gonna watch it
yeah it's the same thing like it's just
like if you're saying why the violence
of that guy you're not seeing any of his
movies
then when he takes it out you'll just be
like it was sort of bland
not a good effort you know exactly but
now we just cater to all them the queefs
and now everything sucks yeah we talk
about tarantino a ton on this because i
i mean i love jackie brown that's one of
my favorite movies of his because it's
like it's got heart too he makes
different types of movies too that's the
thing it's like they try to label him in
a in a box but it's like pulp fiction
reservoir dogs then like once upon a
time in hollywood they're so different
yeah i know that's my favorite of his
once upon a time yeah i just i do i saw
it like three times and the last time i
saw it i saw it in his theater and he
literally had like the the rick dalton
like the leonardo's character he had
like the posters it was total immersive
experience like those movies really
happened yeah it was so awesome
and uh no i just thought it was like you
know leonardo dicaprio's performance
when he's like he's in the scene and
he's got nothing he's trying to like you
know do all this stuff he's just like he
did that so well and then he had that
little speech impediment like every time
i watched it i saw
something else that had one of my
favorite cars of all time it had this i
think it was a 67 cadillac el dorado i
[ __ ] love that car
and then i also like how you know
there's always was this mystique of the
manson family and he just reduced them
to a bunch of lazy [ __ ] who didn't want
to get a job right and i also i think i
noticed this on the third one i don't
know if this is true but i think nobody
says hippie without saying [ __ ] in
front of it it's always [ __ ] hippie
interesting
it's the big thing of margarita [ __ ]
hips yeah
the scene where he's in the trailer and
he drank too much and he [ __ ] up a
line and he's like god damn it what are
you doing i've been there so many times
in like a la canta inn on the road like
why did you say that you [ __ ] idiot
you gotta stop drinking you to write
more that really the self-hatred yes the
self-hatred of that he was going to do
like making fun of his speech impediment
you just saw the whole oh the whole
thing it was you know and peter's just
so mysterious and cool in it like he's
just a cool dude oh
yeah he was awesome i love when he when
he opens that beer and he's got the mask
and like the foam shoots up on his face
a little bit he didn't he's just sitting
there with that that
oh yeah your gun and they kind of leave
it open
so good i think he killed his wife i
don't know
i got to go back and see jackie brown i
have not seen that since i saw it
um in the theaters and i liked it in the
theaters it's just something you know
being in this business you know it's
just so crazy like you're like i gotta
watch that again and all of a sudden 25
[ __ ] years goes by so i got to see
that that's a great one the detail but
also who would pit is it robert
forrester yeah yeah who would pick that
guy then to bring pam grier back i mean
the guy does what he wants
he's got great ideas lawrence tierney
and reservoir dogs come on so you like
to tell jokes
i don't tip
dude samuel jackson's funny [ __ ] in
jackie brown it's just it's just a great
movie yeah
is he your favorite director you think
oh my god um
i'm not so good jesus what do you got
here beer jew today we got root beer
floats
oh my god i heard you liked them
yeah i do but i'm 54 so
uh
thank you i have uh
you know more commitments i feel like if
if i consume that i'm going to need a
nap but
yeah you gotta have also taught not to
waste things you got that right let's
talk about the state of comedy while
drinking a root beer
is that nutmeg where's some of the
edgier comics out here people
eating cotton that's a little chocolate
powder on top you guys have boozy root
beer flows
nothing says summer yeah like a little
bourbon in your root beer float that's
[ __ ] delicious that is good jesus it
is delicious i've been one of these in
12 years i'm gonna say yeah since that
diner
uh in atlantic city
are you are you uh how often are you on
the road bill
right now you know what oh i'm on the
road and i don't care right now because
i have a root beer
this is all i got left
hold on i'm gonna light one of these
puppies i always say that to younger
people like save up some fun days
don't blow out your liver you want to be
that person that paces themselves so you
can booze your whole life so you know if
you want to occasionally you know i
think you need to be a little more
introspective about your habits sorry
i'm kind of moderate come on you've been
there right when they sit there and they
talk about what's an alcoholic what are
you doing like really the bar is that
low oh i see like four drinks a week i'm
like now you're just being an [ __ ]
that's not fair yeah how about the
doctor how many drinks do you have and
you tell him and he's like oh you're
like oh i lied
yeah all these new studies that say like
there's no benefits to being under 40
and drinking
there's none
i like it so much that i don't abuse it
and i think that rings true
even though i do abuse it yeah no i did
too
i did i had a good time though i got my
stories
i'm like
i'm like that old retired guy with the
hall of fame jacket
you know just let me tell you back in
the 80s
i don't know if you know this but
there's a video on youtube of you
calling derosa hammered at like five in
the morning in florida
because he uh he didn't go out and you
went out
and you're like shaming him for taking
it easy that night
no some somebody found it somebody
posted it we must have played it on the
radio show
maybe but you're hammered but you didn't
say anything bad or anything it's not
incriminating i was a happy drunk yeah
yeah same i was probably singing i used
to like to sing yeah won't you come out
joe derosa won't you come out i think
that's in there something that was a big
hit for me
when you're a good drunk it's hard to
quit you know
well there's business too that's why i
don't start back up because i was like
uh like more of like a habit guy
but like i just it's like anything it's
like these [ __ ] things i'll quit them
and then i'm good and then i have one on
a podcast
and then you know i abandoned my family
so that's that's i'm gonna put that on
you guys
well i think hungover with toddlers is
pretty rough i don't think i don't think
that's doable so maybe when i have a
little rugrat i'll cool it with the with
the sauce you know something too
is being downstairs hammered
and there's like the most innocent thing
ever upstairs depending on you yeah like
if somebody came through the door right
now i'd run at them and just
i couldn't drive them to the hospital so
that ate at me um that's tough yeah so i
basically the first year she was born i
just was like i'm gonna take a break and
then i uh i kept doing it and it's good
but these things here i gotta watch out
because you know
kids just pick up on stuff like that you
should never smoke and they're like yeah
you that's you only do that when you're
an adult i'm like [ __ ]
gotta undo that gotta undo that so um
but you know whatever enough about my
failures as a father no no hey my my dad
was a pretty big boozer really schlitz a
comedian
you had a great one
she always said he was proud of you and
asked you how your day was still wait
still waiting
but schlitz is that's an ugly drone
schlitz it was cheap and he would drink
him hot and he would just leave the case
on the floor and just take one out and
to be extra angry yeah
it wasn't pretty and he was always in
boxers
i remember and when you would drive
you'd go hand up
oh yeah my dad was a brief guy
oh yeah what do you what do you do
me oh boxes you spent boxes forever but
everybody was briefs some boxers came in
in like the uh the 90s but up until then
everybody was briefs you just walked
around everybody
yeah you just yeah they were white too
yeah they were white it was just this is
it this is what i'm bringing to the
party yeah
that was a commercial in the 90s boxes
of briefs what's with jordan probably
the boxer brief they do the combat
that's what i do that's what i do you
got a mix no that's what i have you got
boxer brief yeah
that came in later because that was like
a big thing when the boxer brief came in
it was like hey best of both worlds
yeah i don't know that's another thing
it's funny how there's just lies and
everything you don't know what to
believe
it's just like
what's better boxes are bad because your
balls are hanging down and now the other
ones they heat up your balls and your
sperm cow cause that's just like it's
like the egg you know is it good or is
it bad
milk what's wrong with the egg i don't
know they egg has been good bad and good
in my life and i think it's going bad
it's like hulk hogan
he's going bad again
yeah he was the king and then he had
like a sex tape or an animal did you see
that video of the guy bubba the love
sponge where he he was like
i told my wife to [ __ ] him and then the
video got out it was like a whole thing
i think he sued gawker over that and one
yeah he won like 150 million or
something oh i thought that was the
other one yeah when the guy when the the
the wrestler drops the n-word in his
promo oh that's saturday night how cogan
we're coming for you and we're gonna
he was so in it he just forgot where he
was and i just loved how immediate he
was like oh god damn it i said that in
front of white people
he turned down the george foreman grill
that was brought the whole this guy oh
hogan oh he did yeah oh is this it
oh yeah yeah yeah that roy wood in the
back he says sucker he says this is all
good
oh yeah this guy rules he
committed oh so crushing it while
getting the pecs going i know
i don't think there's a ton of black
guys in wrestling
[Music]
damn no no take we can't take that again
huh that was just one take
there's some great ones where they do
outtakes where mean gene is laughing
when someone will say something and then
it oddly sounds like a gay sex act and
he just starts cracking up uh
i don't know i yeah i watch a bunch of
that [ __ ] me and jean was incredible
that dude just knew how to he just you
need a straight man yeah yeah i gotta
tell you people from goodfellas and
wrestlers dying is the saddest thing
about growing old it's just it's like
your favorite movie
you know we got paulie walnuts on the
wall here we love you no he went
yeah
i'm such and i didn't know that was
maria did you read that thing when he
was talking about how he he was going to
try to back out of the movie because he
only played nice guys and he didn't
think that he could do you know sort of
that that ominous thing that he did and
then one day just kind of put the coat
on and he said he he was thinking about
the character and he sort of looked up
in the mirror and he like scared himself
and he's like all right i got this leota
no uh uh paul sauvino
so because paul has a he has a couple of
like i love that moment where he goes
what do you want me to do whack him and
they go hey i don't think that'd be a
bad idea and he just kind of he just
gives him this [ __ ] look
and he's like well i don't mean any
disrespect he's just like oh my god this
guy's gonna end up in a dumpster just
look at that he gave him
um and then also like i love when he's
like when he with the onions when he's
kind of like he's kind of looking down
his nose and just like garlic oh my god
yeah it's just like one
like i feel like the food network should
show that scene
it just makes you want to eat a great
meal of course i can't cut garlic
without thinking about that it's just
burning in my brain that and cuddy sarc
it's just what i like i just like the
how much italians give a [ __ ] just
coming up german irish where they just
threw [ __ ] in a pot yeah it's just like
airport level go [ __ ] yourself but these
guys look at that face it's an art
even in prison yeah beginning of the
pandemic i made pasta like every night
just because you know you bulk it out
and i can't not think of the scene every
time i mean how genius is that so it
liquefies in the pen like how good is
that
yeah my mom has a food podcast shout out
and uh she's like what do you want to
talk about i talked about that scene and
she's like a big you know italian mook
and uh she had never seen that
so it blew her mind she's like i thought
this was like a bloody gangster movie
i'm like no it's scorsese there's
attention to detail
yeah no it and that's also too what's
amazing about that movie is it's just
there's so many like little vignettes
and little stories
within the whole thing
that like you know all of those script
writing classes like everything that he
did it makes no sense and then you watch
it it's just it's just amazing i know
the scene at the dinner with the mom the
hoof that scene's amazing with the guy
one guy go this way one guy that way
that scene's amazing that's like a
little movie in itself the scene with
the wives where they all have herpes
that's a great moment there's a million
of them and everything looked like it
was thrown together
the scene where he wakes up and she's on
top of him with the gun i mean there's
so many memorable images oh yeah [ __ ]
de niro turning the you know clapton
playing i mean oh yeah how about ray
liotta how early that was in his career
and he got thrown in with those guys and
he totally hung with him and they were
like improving and all of that yeah um i
love rayleigh oda man yeah i just i
watched something wild recently again
the other day that's a great leader you
know i never saw i got to see flick he's
he steals it i mean he's incredible he's
so scary in it man
i got to work with him one time he was
really yeah he was cool he was cool as
hell
i came in the makeup trailer he was just
sitting there
and he was in like a suit you know and i
was just like i didn't say anything was
just like wow and then you know i we did
the scene and everything and then he
just
he was really just really like a warm
guy you know you wouldn't think you know
just because of the characters he played
a really like nice guy
and uh we had a couple scenes together
and but that there was like a big amount
of time in them between them we shot the
first one in la and then it was like a
month
or five weeks and we shut the rest in
new york
out like queens or whatever and we on
top of that that uh that silver cup we
shot a scene on the roof of that thing
queens and uh
he came out and uh
i remember because he called my
character skippy
he was giving me [ __ ] you know because i
had the whole ron howard look and he was
just like somebody goes hey what's up
skippy you know [ __ ] with me i just
started laughing and he was like all
amped up you know like to do do the
scene and everything he was just he was
just really really fun just a fun guy
man that's a [ __ ] shame if actors
that big and that iconic get annoyed
with um
guys who kind of blow them and look up
to them and get excited are they like ah
right act like you've been there or you
think they're flattered
uh i think it all depends on the person
so i always just like i just keep my
mouth shut and i just always treat like
if this guy wants to talk to me he will
yeah and then i think usually when
you're just sort of quiet you're just
doing your job and they think you're
doing all right then eventually they get
okay this guy's a pro he's not gonna ask
for a [ __ ] picture yeah i remember
when we did that scene when that scene
was over there was some extra in it
um
and the scene ended and it was
downstairs at the bar and he was like
walking up the stairs and this extra was
like right on his hip
the whole way up talking about this
script that he had
and ray was being nice and everything
and like now looking back i'm like they
should have had somebody to be like hey
hey hey
yeah yeah get a handle this isn't this
isn't how this works yeah
you know he's like this is my shot oh
and he pulls it out of his
sweaty back did you hear that arnie
adams story where
when seinfeld was shooting comedian the
documentary they were going around to
local guys and going what do you think
of jerry and he goes i think he's a lot
of touch i think he's kind of losing it
his fastball's gone and jerry saw that
and goes put him in the movie he's got
the balls and then he made a movie
making him look like [ __ ] well you know
this that was a twist i know but then
there's this talk of like did he do that
to [ __ ] him over ultimately or you know
but it's all hearsay
but i thought that was interesting he's
like he's got balls to be honest put him
in
yeah and that becomes a good part of the
movie then also like that got me like
amped up if somebody said that
about me i'd be like all right i'm gonna
i you know you wouldn't be you wouldn't
be hurt
out of touch that's harsh
no
you just gotta go all right you know
take it and just be like all right this
might be the kind of day he had but it
might be maybe i am
well tell you billy
that's why i'm down here with you young
guys i'm trying to hang on to the
younger audience
that's some great advice from bill about
uh go to the club see the young guys and
uh
always you gotta stay away from young
guys keep you young if you just [ __ ]
you know make it and start selling
tickets and you stop doing the clubs
what ends up happening is you grow old
with your audience and you guys just all
end up in some sad casino in the middle
of nowhere when you're in your 80s
yeah uh i've seen those shows i've gone
to those shows both singers and um
and comedians and uh i still go out
because i love the older guys and all
that and uh but i i've you know you see
the ones that are still having fun
and you see the ones clearly feeling
like you know i used to be able to pack
a place twice besides
i just feel that vibe and it's just like
all right you're making us all feel like
losers for being here and then uh yeah
one of the best shows i saw i saw tony
orlando wow
dawn
tie a yellow ribbon and knock three
times open for don rickles wow what dude
they both
how long ago oh my god uh i was still
drinking
i heckled don rickles
because i knew i was gonna meet him i
had to have an interaction i was a
little drunk i waited till his encore uh
he who's on there i just kept going
donnie
i didn't say
and then he do a few more jokes
and then i go donnie and then he just
kind of looked out
basically where i was sitting he goes
yeah i know my name
is like yes
interaction
yeah no there's a there's a whole bunch
of people uh
as far as their crew these two and joe
list
um love all of those guys uh
bianca chris de vaio who did um um
stephen colbert last night yeah she got
the big you know the whole uh you know
the first time you do a late night spot
i mean that's [ __ ] nerve-wracking
and those don't mean i know they don't
do what they used to do but they still
mean a lot to me but it's still
nerve-wracking because
if you kill no one's going to see it but
if you eat it like everybody's going to
see it epic fail on stephen colbert or
on kimmel or whatever so yeah um we all
know which one you're talking about on
kimmel by the way yeah there's what did
i bomb on that no no it was but there
was one that really made the rounds on
kimball that oh i wasn't talking about
that oh okay i don't watch it and i
don't want to i don't want to see
anybody
no i don't want i didn't want to watch
it i don't like watching that [ __ ] that
makes me i put on loop really no i can't
watch that [ __ ] it's hard i could never
watch any of my friends
on on late night tv i just couldn't but
there was one
uh
there was this one uh that we used to do
uh last call with carson daly that's a
tough one that was a tough one because
yeah well carson was great but like the
crowd they would just get this crazy mix
of people
from like times square some who didn't
even speak english and you just went up
there and basically bombed
um i remember tom papa telling me goes i
used to like watching that show when my
friends were on and just call them up
and just start laughing but
it wasn't like malicious from tom
because he knew he was gonna go right
and he was gonna eat it too but it was
like the band would always be laughing
carson would always be laughing and then
you'd be like how was that encouragement
that was great it was great but then
even if you were killing there was only
like 11 people there because it was yeah
i remember what russman eve said on
there where the jokes were killer and he
was just getting nothing really yeah he
uh he by the way russell neve one of my
all-time favorite jokes where he says uh
i have bad luck with women my last four
pregnant girlfriends died in sailing
accidents
that's a great joke amazing uh he had
some killer jokes but yeah that set i
remember watching those sets and being
like this looks like a hell gig and it's
televised i would have thought that
because it's loose it's like almost like
a 60s show or this oh there was one
worse than that they had this one called
friday night videos
that i did back in the day with patrice
and it was basically the crowd was
whoever didn't leave the tonight show
whoever they could convince to stay
so it was like going to like a royals
game where there was all these empty
seats and [ __ ]
and then they would throw like a drop
cloth over jay's desk and then they
would hang this thing that said friday
night videos
and uh oh my god oh my god did we bomb
on that
yes i did it with patrice patrice went
out and they go
and he you know he was he knew he knew
he wasn't going to do well so he just
sabotaged his set remember they said
don't curse and he came out i mean a big
stupid patrice just comes out he goes ah
[ __ ]
i was so mad i was like ah why didn't i
do that they're gonna show mine and they
never aired his i was joking he had his
back to the audience doing half his act
i said you [ __ ] went like miles davis
mode
well he was such a he had that move
where like if he's going to bomb he's
going to [ __ ] you too you know he'll
make you feel bad also i'm not just
going to be the one feeling dumb
you're going to suffer too i'm putting
my back he was in cursive yeah he was a
quitter
he saw it and he just said i'm not doing
it my dumb ass was just like i'm gonna
make it happen yeah
that's how i was by the way kimmel shout
out to kimmel he discovered carson daly
adam corolla and
what's the guy the sports guy bill
simmons
that's all kimmel really fun quite a
coaching tree
oh god
there you go there's one at every party
you gotta reach with those long arms
there
yeah never did kill i heard it was the
worst stand-up camel yeah because uh
they would take everybody to another
room
and then you do you perform so
everybody's like what the [ __ ] i
remember geraldo said on there that was
like great
great jokes and just nothing they were
they gave me nothing i never saw that
one yeah uh and that and now they do it
i think in his comedy club in vegas so
you're not even on set yeah you're in
vegas rather do it that way in vegas
yeah yeah at a club for sure in vegas
well yeah because you don't even feel
like you're doing the show it's it's
just i would rather do it he's probably
helping you out
as opposed to just going out there with
those people you know just got off the
[ __ ] pirates of the caribbean ride
and then you go up there with your
[ __ ] hitler joke and they're just
like
you know all you ever hear is the band
laughing and you want to be like the
band is laughing okay this this is uh
this is doing i'm doing well here yeah
it's funny how nervous those crowds are
i did a thing on fallon like two weeks
ago and i threw out a joke and i
remember thinking like this is gonna hit
and it got zero and it's the worst
feeling because you're like that is on
tape and now fallon hates me
my favorite one to ever watch was andy
kindler
i saw him on this this short-lived talk
show i still remember the joke this
before i even did stand-up and i was
watching that guy me and my brothers
were all just dying laughing and he just
he said uh
this is the joke he did in front of a
bunch of tourists
he goes you know whenever whenever uh
barbara walters interviews
uh robin williams
she always says oh you guys i was
watching it and she goes robin we are
always funny
and robin said yes and i wanted to be
like really well what happened
he goes
jumanji right and he's
just staring at him
and at one point during the set he goes
i choose to plow ahead rather than
looking at the burning wreckage of the
last joke and nobody first thing that he
came out he [ __ ] on the whole place
saying the ceiling was too high like he
was playing some hell room and he was
like on tv
and i just never seen anybody
anybody do that and his jokes
were amazing um damn yeah it was just
one of those uh
one of those things yeah yeah i always
you know you hear about those stories of
him going to the comedy store and just
leveling like they said it was the roof
would come off it was energy in the room
and then you heard i stole half of it
that was like oh i think i'm about kind
of like robin williams oh sorry robin
williams yeah yeah jesus christ sorry
about russia trash and kimmel that's a
dangerous podcast i'm losing gigs right
and left over here i'm a fan i like
kibble i i talked about how he uh
discovered people yeah yeah uh robin
williams man that's like did you know
him at all or no
no i did i did improv with them one time
really what how was that was that yeah
it was just one of those moments i was
in um
it's like [ __ ]
ucb
uh like the original one out in la that
that first one before they had the
second one uh franklin yeah the one on
franklin and i went down there and jeff
garland had a show and he would do this
thing where he'd give away some stuff
from his house he'd do a little stand up
and bring people out normal comedy show
and in the end he had this improv game
called the combo platter where three
people would sit in a chair somebody
started a story and then you killed tag
and you just went up there it was fun
and uh we were there and robin showed up
and in the end he played and i remember
he was i was sitting like right here and
he was like he was sitting it was funny
like three four inches away from me but
his arm hair was still touching my arm
i remember all those jokes that he did
on live aid about how hairy he was i was
like that is iconic arm hair
needless to say i sucked in the improv
game because i was i was like
going like i just that was that was you
know one of many of those moments where
you just like you feel like you get like
sucked into your tv like i was i've
watched this guy for a decade
uh
probably longer at that point um it
wasn't i don't even know when it was
2000s damn something like that yeah it
was um
it was something he was a super nice guy
just really uh
really like just regular
you wouldn't know that he did all of the
stuff that he did he just really just
seemed like just still the same guy he's
a comic so yeah i just watched that
episode of louie that he was on oh it's
such a great app were they they're just
at the funeral for those they're the
only two people there it was yeah i mean
yeah he was
he was so good man he was great on gary
larry sanders show
uh a long time ago he came on as a yeah
oh he just came on as a guest and he got
into it with larry
and i just remember when they went to
commercial and larry was giving him [ __ ]
about trashing him or something he goes
whatever he goes it's a business blow me
just the way he said it
you know you're really thinking like wow
like i guess on talk shows like the host
doesn't always like the guests like sort
of the first sort of
peek into that because you know when
you're at home watching it you just
think like oh these guys are on tv they
just must hang out and drink and there's
groupies and you know back like the
whole you know uh um
anchorman vibe right the whole time i
was growing up like that that's why that
that movie hit so hard
with me was it was just like that's yeah
that's the way like the news was
like dude local news like the [ __ ]
names
there was a guy a newscaster in in
boston named tony pepper
like that's like a shortstop name tony
pepper yeah he was the [ __ ] chet curtis
jack williams they had all of those
names and there was always like these
hot women then one of them would end up
marrying a banging one of them right
yeah there is tony pepper look at that
guy he's like a playboy tony absolutely
was
tony tony pepper i'm sure did very well
the head swag in the greater boston area
yeah jack williams he had wednesday's
child he was helping the kids nah bob
lobel would come in
and he would do the local sports
bob neumeyer i remember all of those
guys dick albert did the the [ __ ]
weather yeah there was a guy on new york
one and he had like such an ego he used
to hang at the seller all the time he
was the film guy like he'd be like i
give this one three apples that was this
whole thing how many apples and he would
just hang at the cellar and i remember
really he was so cocky he like you
thought everyone recognized him like he
got i recognized him so he immediately
was like clearly everyone here knows me
i'm like no i just watched new york one
i remember he like kind of walked over
to michael che like
new york one and shay was just like yeah
i have fios i don't i don't know who you
are it was like the cruelest shutdown
because he expected everyone to know is
that him
no it's not that's not the same whipple
that guy that guy you recognize i don't
know who was the other guy gene
something rather what the charlotte
gentility oh my god back in the day film
critics were like stars celebrities i
mean two thumbs up
look at that [ __ ]
that guy could take your movie out and
there's nothing you could do about it
like what's that movie from the fifth of
the sweet smell of
success that's back in the day when
they're like i'll destroy you in my
column and that means something right oh
yeah big time big time the last time i
remember like uh
i remember this guy he somewhere
somebody had opened a restaurant i'm
gonna deliberately forget the name
opened a restaurant here in times square
and this guy
wrote this review that was just all
questions
and it was [ __ ] hilarious it was just
like uh is there a reason the chicken is
gray
why does you know why does the menu look
like a [ __ ] you know dmv test
whatever the hell it was but it was just
like it was the whole
it was like
this guy's experience
sucked
the whole i can't remember yeah you know
you don't need to be trashing these
people come on
[Laughter]
we all take a pig we all take a hit
google me there's plenty of people
[ __ ] on me i never ate this so you
know but it was this guy went like like
literally the review went viral oh it
was um how do you do that to somebody
though that's so cruel like who who's
this guy maybe your friend every tick
tock now is just like raiding
restaurants like there's so many people
that make a living just like starting
like we're gonna see the best places to
eat
there's just dudes in cars like 4.7 yeah
like that's someone's life this burger
is better than this burger shake that's
someone's life you're [ __ ] dude dave
portnoy from bar stool sports like his
influence like people want him to come
to the pizza place and they don't
they're like if this guy doesn't like
our pizza like we are [ __ ] oh yeah but
i gotta be honest yeah i literally like
helping i watch your [ __ ] i i want like
when i go to a certain area i just go i
just i dave porting my pizza i'll be
like there you go like new haven or
something like you know the pizza
capital of the world what's his favorite
one there's some place out in jersey
there's brick oven one yep that he said
this one's the best so it's like i got
to get to that one
um because there's been a few that he
went to that i loved i'm like here comes
a big number and he's still in the
sevens me too
i think it was arturo's in the in like
the west village i [ __ ] love that
place yeah and he trashed and i was like
this is a good [ __ ] pizza place wait
but it's also good because if he trashes
it then you don't have to stand in a
long line for two
true
but
pull up the video of him he's doing a
pizza shop on the first avenue
yeah it's portnoy and it's the funniest
video because he can't even get to the
pizza review because all these weirdos
in new york keep [ __ ] with them and
it's so cle it's much it feels like it's
written it's so there's so much comedy
in it on accident
not a portnoy video
it's a place on first avenue it started
in staten island they moved to a first
avenue location so here's something
better than a root beer float is the
unexpected root beer float yeah no idea
that was good i feel like it's my
birthday
taste the booze by the way yeah i'd like
20 more but i'm not going to i can't
no one wants to see a fat bald ginger
i've learned that the hard way
i think you've got the bourbon one [ __ ]
huh i think you got the one with bourbon
in it on accident
bill we talk about something you said if
it's by accident we we talk about
something you say i don't know if you
said an interview or something we talk
about in this pod all the time is that
you talk about killing an obscurity yeah
and those like weird cities like me and
uh geraldo that's what i used to do
because every place i was doing
uh
he was either was just there or was
coming there the next week
and um
you know we were getting the same
reviews from everybody that we were
playing you know performing in the
middle of nowhere they well they were
the funniest guys you know they never
ever played here in the first five six
times you hear that you're like all
right okay things are gonna happen and
then like eight years of your career
comes by just like
i still remember that time when i was i
was at you know i'd done a third show
and i was just sitting there this is
back when you could still smoke in the
clubs and literally my eyes are burning
everything about me just reeks of smoke
like i just fought a fire and i was just
sitting there watching the wait staff
counting
up the money and stuff and you know i'd
gone there for years and i kind of knew
everybody i was just looking
everywhere's a little older everyone was
a little fatter and i was just all of
this i just got my head like going like
oh my god i'm the guy
i'm not gonna make it
i was just like i was going like i don't
know how much longer i can do this right
and i forget what i i had to do
something the next day but it was like
terrifying like i went back to the
comedy condo just laying there going
like no it's not gonna happen i just
gotta stay positive just keep writing
jokes and it's eventually you just keep
doing a good job i have to let you in
somewhere
in a weird way that probably made you
better though like
if you i think if you think i'll never
make it it kind of lets you not give a
[ __ ] and then you can get really loose
and weird and try [ __ ]
definitely you have to try to make it
with what you want to do
because then you won't have any regrets
like well
this is what i do this is how i do it
and people don't respond so
[ __ ] it but if you're actually trying to
be what you think that they want or some
bad advice you get from a manager in
asia
you know like did you have managers say
that they said that to you like be
something else
um did i ever have that no i'm kind of
blaming them i think a lot of it was me
i would just look around and be like all
right everybody you know there was this
weird i always talk about this this is a
weird time in the business for about 18
months where comedians and agents both
dressed the same at the laugh factory
and it was like these black polyester
[ __ ] like slacks with like a tucked
in electric blue button down like that
was the [ __ ] look and i was just like
all right i have blue eyes this could
bring out my eyes
maybe maybe this still be something that
they like and it was just always like uh
he wore that on letterman once
i don't remember that was a long time
ago but i was just i just remember i
would always get the same thing he's
funny he just has a weird look it's like
i know redheads aren't the lead oh [ __ ]
yourself i know what you're saying so
like
yeah so it was kind of that uh
and then like i don't know somewhere i
was just like all right this is this is
not
you know when you put on the monkey suit
you still don't get the [ __ ] pat on
the head you're like all right
i hate myself at a whole new level and
i'm not doing this again so then that's
why i started going up like just sort of
being who i was and
another 15 years went by and then here i
am
well that's how it goes but at least in
our day we can go kill and put it on
youtube back then it was you were
living and dying by that gatekeeper
yeah and i remember when when
like your generation you know i don't
know if it was yours what generation is
bo burnham is he before you i think he's
younger he's like 30. he's younger than
a third i feel like he popped way before
us yeah but i remember when he came out
like his first gig he like totally sold
out the comedy connection six shows and
there was all these
older comics going oh this is [ __ ]
he didn't play his dues or anything i'm
just sitting there going like
yeah but he didn't have to do like
you know this is kind of genius right
and then now like you look at what he's
doing
i mean that guy's one of the like that
he's telling gerard carmack the way that
was shot off
i [ __ ] loved that special i really
loved that special the second one and
then chris rock saw it and goes do
tambourine which is the ultimate
compliment huh what do you guys think
about his quarantine special i thought
it was great super impressive yeah it
was cool that was great insanely hard he
edits it he shoots it he lights it he
writes it it's andy
he's like a triple double guy in
basketball he does like everything yeah
he's like and music yeah he's got it all
yeah and he's 6 8
[Music]
and he's dreamy
[Laughter]
yeah he's there's nothing stopping him
oh yeah i remember some of you earlier
like the bits that i was like oh [ __ ]
bill is so kind of different like the
muffin bit where you're just punching
the muffins in front of the woman's face
i remember that's a true story dude i
was on the upper west side when i still
remember that we went there i was
[ __ ] dying laughing my girlfriend is
now my wife the lovely nia was just
going like what are you it was one of
those things i was laughing so hard that
she had no idea was laughing she was
laughing at how hard i was laughing and
i was trying to explain it to her and
she was just like you know what if i
just started punching them up
why would you think
why would you think that
well that bit and then the bit about uh
when malice in the palace and you kind
of you defended the players like the way
you said were like athletes
and still do yeah and still do like that
was one of the that was like
some of the great like that was like a
great revenge flick like a movie
right like
the fact that that guy threw a beer on
another man that size he never would
have done that in a bar the only tragedy
was he grabbed the wrong guy yeah yeah
which was the comedy of it right you
know it was it was like now they're
friends really yeah oh [ __ ] the david
ran our test documentary they like they
they're buddies yeah i met that guy a
couple of times he like you just don't
you don't even understand how
big a human being those basketball
players are and like
you know and you watch like and all of a
sudden you meet him and then like the
next night you're watching a game and
you watch him try to take a charge and
go flying across the floors like there's
another human being
i'm saying you know i'm not didn't flop
like he just stood there for the charge
and just goes flying it's just like
if you re-watch that there's a guy in
the in the movie or whatever the
documentary where he's like squaring up
this little guy a little oh yeah and i'm
like who the [ __ ] is this guy this guy
should have his own doc the balls on
that guy he's on the floor like let's go
and it gets broken a little bit of a
reached yet to uh germain
o'neal
yeah big dude
yeah exactly
he's lucky he threw that big long
i mean that's one of those guys i
remember
this guy i worked in a warehouse and
this guy six foot six punched me in the
head
and i just so didn't think i was in his
wheelhouse and i kind of hop back and it
just kept coming
he [ __ ] clocked me in the back of the
head and i just saw these stars and i
just been thinking like god damn this
guy's a big [ __ ] dude why do you hate
you
oh here we go because i was mouthing off
to him i totally deserved it
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah ben wallace that's
usually bigger dudes like ron artest
pushes ben wallace and then he's like
yeah ben wallace is bigger than ron
artest wow yeah ben wallace ben wallace
makes you go to the gym
i gotta do something here i can't have a
guy walking around looking like that and
i'm doing this jesus it's hard to it's
hard to stay in shape doing this job
you're just always flying and [ __ ]
you're just always kind of out of it you
know yeah and then you're sad yeah you
just order bad food yeah
yeah and working out would actually make
us feel better but
yeah you just got to get down there i
was going to do it i didn't i took the
red eye last night so i was just like ah
the red eye
then i had a bad coffee at a place where
that's all they do
that's like yeah we gotta get a food
review on that coffee place
i'm not doing that maybe i got a bad
thing but they were like it's like an
italian
you know it's like the coffee i got in
italy which i never i
just started drinking coffee this year
what you never drink coffee no i just
never i i just how do you do morning
radio and stuff and hangovers
just german irish plow through it damn
wow
i started 33 with coffee which was
already late
but i can't believe you just started
what are you 61
no i'm not quite 54. i might as well be
i'll be 61. should have gone higher for
the comedic effects
oh i just realized nobody laughed
they're like are you
[Laughter]
yeah i've been doing this probably
longer than you've been alive
um
damn mm-hmm
well
you're gonna be right with the root beer
float i think about that chappelle line
twice a week where he goes what you're
doing is gonna take longer but when it
hits it hits
because as a comic
you know just
kind of struggling today
he said that to you when you were on
youtube yeah i'm like [ __ ] like five
years older than him but he started at
14. so i still look at him like a big
brother
and then every once in a while like you
know
i'll see something that'll say his age
and i'm like that's right he's younger
than i am yeah but like as far as comedy
years
you know i mean he started like
uh god they started he was like 14. yeah
fourteen like 86 or something so it's
like it's been a comic more than he's
been like a human that's just crazy yeah
i've done i'm i'm past that too i've
been doing it 30 years i'm 54 so
the first 23 and a half years of my life
i wasn't now
yeah damn
the racial draft is one of my favorites
that must have been fun as hell to shoot
that
yeah because it was one of those things
where you're showing up and it's there's
not that pressure because it's already
written and then you sort of open it up
with like improv and like that little
handshake that we did we came up with
that me and the other actor's name
escapes me right now came up with that
and i was so excited when that killed
uh
big thighs no felonies never got a laugh
but i had so many people come up and
quoted
that's that's the only thing nice about
youtube comments is uh when you have a
line in your act it never really hits
but you like it and then youtube they'll
be like they'll quote that line and i'm
like i needed that that was nice yeah
somebody noticed
yep but sir i cut off your chappelle
story it was boring ah all right well
the most things were right
what was it like doing uh i'm sure
you've been asked this a million times
but i i've never heard the breaking bad
stuff that must have been awesome yeah
oh yeah if you've noticed my career i
haven't really done anything other than
parrot troop into other people's genius
smart
a couple of
sketches on chappelle couple episodes of
breaking bad
uh
i know i got a couple others in the
other mandalorian yeah just like
everybody's just like hey and you've
never seen star wars right no no i saw
it oh i saw but one time i saw it i just
i was too i liked empire that's the
first one i saw i liked it and then i
saw the first one i thought it was like
kind of boring in the beginning when
they were in the desert i was like oh my
god somebody shoot somebody right
and then uh
and then the last one you know it was
like by the time like the last one came
out i mean i was like 16 or 17 so like
you know like ewoks and [ __ ] i liked
when they were going through the force
with like the sla i was i was as far as
like sci-fi i liked you like uh escape
from new york yeah blade runner yeah i
like the i believe they say dystopian
tale there you go the dark stuff what's
the one with clive owen from a few years
ago children of man that was [ __ ]
cool great i like i like watching uh
yeah
[ __ ] like that and yeah
that was a good that's a good one
that's a great korean guy yeah guy did
parasite i got a good french one you
should see uh a prophet which came out
in 2009 it's all in french it's [ __ ]
amazing
all right
amazing
the one that uh uh ryan gosling did it
and yeah i loved it
yeah yeah i know i i love all right the
original is amazing yeah that [ __ ]
movie really is the [ __ ] thriller yeah
that's a [ __ ] uh well he's going to
prison it's not a comedy
um
yeah it's uh yeah amazing amazing
amazing movie
all right so what are your favorite
movies
um
probably the same stuff that you guys
like i i like you know
i don't mind like absurd [ __ ] i i do
really like a lot of absurd stuff and
silly stuff
um that like
like all like that adam mckay stuff
before he started making these oscar
movies like a lot of that stuff like i
just [ __ ] love it
and uh is that will ferrell yeah all the
will ferrell uh john c ryan i mean the
two of them oh my god and ricky bobby
talladega like just the outtakes like
how funny and how fast those guys are
with sasha baron cohen too yeah steve
carell like a 40 year old virgin that
that scene that um
kevin hart has in that movie yeah is
this your boy is this your boy yeah
kevin [ __ ] in the store yeah he's so
funny yeah
yeah it was like that whole thing
i watched that the other day and uh
yeah i don't know i i like uh
yeah
i i do like [ __ ] that's sort of but i
definitely my favorite stuff is stuff
that's like
like tethered to uh
reality like i love something like you
know one of my favorite comedies that
came out a few years ago was uh the nice
guys oh yeah i love that movie
um um russell crowe russell crowell
looking great russell crowe's [ __ ]
amazing in that so ryan gosling's when
he breaks his arm that high-pitched
scream he does that's funny every time
and then the guy i always forget his
name the guy playing the bad guy
so creepy john boy or whatever yeah the
choices he makes yeah that line if you
don't tell me what i want i'm gonna
start cutting off your fingers and he
like laughs and if you don't tell us he
goes we're just we're gonna start
cutting off your fingers he like gets
into it just like oh my god this guy's a
lunatic
that's such an underrated movie man it
is it is and it's one of those ones that
somehow
came and went but that is like a that's
so
like if you're on the road yeah you know
back in the day when you bring your dvds
out with the attachment and your [ __ ]
30 pound uh
laptop you bring that one yeah yeah
i i completely agree with the reality
needs something based in reality like i
tried to watch dune and i know people
love it and all that i just couldn't do
it i i turned it off
yeah when it gets too far into the
future that i that i don't get uh i like
the ones where it's the future it's on
earth and there's [ __ ] left over when i
was alive right and i think that that's
you know they go into an old subway
station or something like i like that
type of [ __ ] we're gonna get torn apart
in the comments for shouldn't undo by
the way those [ __ ] people i'm just
saying i'm not saying it's bad it's like
doing a mad max one no it's a similar
kind of yeah it's like futuristic mad
max wasn't that bad speaking of yeah the
things left over from the real world the
first two mad maxes that was just oh
thunder dome yeah there was just them
driving through like the australian
outback yeah yeah i like walking rat
rods the original rat rods yeah tina
turner's in that yeah you need that
comfort watch on there i've been
watching like veep on the right i just
need something silly as hell on the road
to just i've been watching that uh i
think it's called the uh
the bear or something like that oh i
just finished it oh yeah i'm only two
episodes in but like it's so well shot
yeah i know a couple of people that work
in that they go is there really
screaming like that they're like
yeah
like i know this chef she worked uh with
some guy here in new york that was rated
the worst person to work for oh wow
whatever she brings up that she works
with them like almost other chefs like
ah i'm sorry it's not like that here wow
it's just like uh
like she was saying that she's a woman
that guy would come up with like step on
her feet when she was [ __ ] stuff up
it's just like i had football coaches
like that in third grade yeah they come
and [ __ ] kick you in the side of your
leg because you couldn't hold your
little third grade legs up that's
basically gordon ramsay he's just a
football coach yelling at you
i worked as a woman oh did you ever see
that time that guy snapped
cause he i used to sit there yelling at
those guys as he's firing him and
they're literally like wrapping up all
their [ __ ] steak knives and [ __ ] it's
like dude you might want to be on the
other side of the counter
and at one point this [ __ ] it was a
new york dude he's like you don't know
me [ __ ] he said flip out i was
like yeah there you go somebody with
some self-esteem he's kicking you off
you might as well go out with a spark
right it's on tv
what's that guy the bar rescue guy the
big guy john taff taffer somebody went
off on him once at like a harlem
restaurant and i was like all right it's
about time
and even he was like okay let's uh let's
change scenes
let's move it along here dude is
entertaining though so yeah he is i love
that guy i love the way he cooks and all
that [ __ ] but it's just like there is
something funny when somebody thinks
they're in this fame yeah force field
and that someone's not gonna step
through it just be like this is
invisible you're a person and i will
[ __ ] you up and it's like oh that's
right i haven't been a person for a
while yes that's what i've just been
sort of shuttled
to and from the gig and over to the
airport
yeah that's why the mike tyson punch on
the plane was so fun you're like yeah
yeah what do you think was gonna happen
you [ __ ] with this it's mike tyson
murderer yeah he'll kill you yeah that
was pretty twitter
that was awesome how desperate was that
and he just he wanted to get hit so he
could do the whole [ __ ] thing with
the guy filming it and [ __ ] and like
it's really weird
i know you'll take a punch from mike
tyson for the clicks oh that's a fun
still looks terrifying oh yeah come on i
know but he's in shape some of those
boxers yeah look oh
that's like i don't know is that many
oh he's going
oh that was all rights
jesus christ look at this [ __ ] idiot
oh my god
first class if i was the captain of that
plane i would throw that kid out the
[ __ ] oh yeah geez we have the same
haircut too
how did he get hit on the left on the
right side she's probably like this oh
yeah
[ __ ] that's that guy the claim to fame
like can that get you laid can you go to
a bar and go you know i'm the mike tyson
guy i bet it can't i'm the guy who got
the [ __ ] kicked out of him there's a lot
of dumb ladies out there
[Laughter]
just so you know it's been proven i
can't defend you if there's an intruder
coming up
would you like to go home with me
now word from our sponsor better help
you have to take care of your mind folks
we spend so much time taking care of our
skin our hair our teeth and so little
care of the most important body part the
brain
how well you take care of your brain
affects how you experience life
investing time and energy and mental
health is crucial to being happy eating
right working out and getting plenty of
sleep or a good start but no
substitution for talk therapy better
help makes online therapy accessible
convenient and affordable we love
therapy it's good for you don't let
those bags pile up everybody's got [ __ ]
in their life everybody's got drama you
got to make it work you got to be
healthy and that's how you do it is
talking about it that's how you get it
out better help is online therapy offers
video phone and chat therapy sessions
you can choose to not see anyone on
camera and it's much more affordable
than in person you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours we might be
drunk listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's
t e r h e l p
dot com slash drunk get on it we might
be drunk is sponsored by fanimel this is
the summer you're going to go out and do
[ __ ] if you want the best price for the
best shows this season use fanimel
fanimal has tickets to everything with
no fees the price you see is the price
you pay for hot tickets to a dodger game
or lady gaga fan mall is always the
cheapest option fanimal's group purchase
makes it easy to get your friends
together set a size for you and your
group you choose a number of tickets you
want to pay for yourself then invite
friends when the group size is met
everyone gets charged and receives their
ticket if the minimum size isn't reached
in time nobody gets charged don't commit
until your friends do fandiml has
amazing customer service don't take our
word for it check out their hundreds of
five star reviews the next time you need
tickets go to fandimo.com and sign up
with code drunk for twenty dollars of
credit toward your first purchase check
out fanimal and experience more
fanimal
all right
support the show and get twenty dollars
off your first per purchase with the
code drunk at uh fanimal.com
looking for something different to cover
up that hole in your wall disc plate is
that cool new metal poster that you'll
want in every room they have millions of
cool designs available featuring gaming
movies comics and anime displayed also
features officially licensed designs
including star wars netflix and many
more uh lots of cool stuff you can get
on this site it only takes 20 seconds to
hang a display no power tools needed no
damages
no frustrations you know i'm a very
irritable person i have no uh housing
skills so this comes in handy once you
mount one you can switch out a new plate
and a flash with everyone that you buy
disc plate plants a tree
click the link in our description to see
some of our favorite displays and save
up to twenty nine percent get twenty
five percent off when you buy one or two
and twenty nine percent off when you buy
three or more discounts will
automatically be applied to your cart
when you click the link or use code
drunk when you visit display.com that's
display.com code drunk or click that
link in our show notes yeah that's
what's fun about like well he threw no
punches no that's the thing so like
you know i don't know i don't know yeah
i think that you should be able to do
that just in life
and there should be no lawsuit and like
the judge just be like well what did you
think was gonna happen stop wasting my
time i'm finding you 75 for wasting this
courts time get the [ __ ] out of here
go learn how to fight or shut the [ __ ]
up next that's a better society that way
i think i think it kind of regulates
itself
but yeah like hockey there you go
your number one sport boss i feel like
boston people love hockey dude i love
them all yeah i love like he talks about
basketball
yeah yeah yeah i've been
watching the red sox and i you know
what's weird is i actually enjoy a
struggling season
more so than them you know it's fun to
watch when they win but i just love
watching like a manager trying to plug
the holes like dude we just i'm tired of
[ __ ] starting rotations out devers
was out [ __ ] hernandez everybody's out
like i was watching the other night i
was watching they playing they were
playing the astros right and they were
just kind of i was going like there's
like five who the [ __ ] are these who's
playing second where's trevor's story
right like what happened to him like he
just like this year with the the socks
it was like if you miss like three games
you come back you don't even recognize
the team it's it's like the worcester
red
all
sox
we playing tonight now we got the
yankees [ __ ]
um was it nerve-wracking being i saw you
did a little commentating
you killed that was awesome i know it
was it was uh
it's fun you know it's fun and it's like
surreal and uh
no i would like i'd say if i had to
announce any sport
uh there's definitely periods where i'd
pick different sports but just generally
speaking if i can't pick the era i would
definitely do baseball because i just
think there's just something like
so much fun
about like you know like when there's
like a rain delay and those guys just
have to like you know if you get like a
guy that's lived life like hawk
harrelson and uh you know uh uh r.i.p
vince scully man just yeah yeah i know
vince kelly wasn't yeah and he said the
most
painful
[ __ ] thing i ever heard and thank god
it was him you know the little roller to
buckner
behind the bag and i guess what it was
night or whatever and then that's
winning
and the greatest thing was when the
socks finally won and 04 like i can
watch that
and just
i can be amazed
at how like they asked clemens one time
what's the most amazing thing you ever
saw he was like us losing the 86 world
series i mean dude we were literally
down to the last strike and we let up
like nine singles in a row
it was just [ __ ]
it was bananas and a lot of people
forget we went up three nothing in game
seven and i still had hope because i was
a young red sox fan and i i missed the
bucky dent thing i was watching them
that year but i didn't watch i just
remember asking my mother i go did we
win and she just switched
and it took her like another 12 years
to fully give herself
into loving them again wow no dude that
was a um
that was you know and that's back when
you could like really just like there
was like great sports like when the
yankees went up we played a five-game
series and they came up and they they
won all five in a row and they called it
the boston massacre yeah you could never
you know isn't that you know making
light of actual match like i remember
that wide receiver yeah it's gonna be a
war this sunday and people like um
there's actually people fighting real
wars it's just like i understand that
you let him get amped up yeah two things
can exist yeah exactly mad when the i'm
a yankees fan but i wasn't mad when the
red sox won you know because that's what
all you yankee fans said she didn't want
to take the [ __ ] i'm happy for you guys
you all [ __ ] went underground
[Laughter]
took a yankee cap off i could not find a
yankee fan in 0-4 oh three they were all
over the place hey [ __ ] whatever that
guy's name is
because it didn't stick aaron boone oh
that was everybody because everybody
thinks like that one hurt it's like it
didn't because it didn't have time to
marinate like a fine wine that walk off
it was just like he did it and then it
was just in the very next year you know
we hung the biggest choke [ __ ] that
was ever
it's the biggest choke in sports just
because it's like a 200 million team
with so many future hall of famers and
like that's also why i don't get mad at
what the astros did because what the red
sox and yankees we were fielding 180
million 200 roided up free agent teams
and we were just winning these
championships like i never even when we
played the [ __ ] colorado rockies in
2007 i think we swept them i didn't even
watch it i was like this is stupid like
we've literally become
like we can't call them the evil empire
anymore it's just like
you know i can't believe it's like dad
you're a drunkard it's like dad you're a
drug addict and then like two days later
you're [ __ ] doing here
you need to get your [ __ ] together
you know but baseball was never better
than in the 90s when when mcguire and
sosa were just oh that was it and it was
[ __ ] amazing and bonds i mean when
when you knew bonds was going to hit a
there's going to be a dude in a kayak
chasing a home rumble every day
dude that was awesome i went to see
mcguire that year down in uh qualcomm
stadium was uh cardinals versus the uh
the uh the padres and i and i mean this
other comedian dan smith went down um
and he hit number 28 at the end of may
right but aaron judge is kind of on that
pace so i remember everybody came up for
like the place was like three quarters
full for batting practice and he came up
and the whole place was like wow
and he got up there like just [ __ ] v
yeah and it was so funny everyone was
going nuts and the first pitch came in
he laid down a bun everybody goes
and dude people were hitting home runs
but when he started hitting them like
other people hit home runs you were
trying to catch him he was hitting these
[ __ ] lasers he's like i don't want to
touch that i'm like i'm gonna let that
go off three people and then when it
hits the ground i'll try to beat an
eight-year-old out for the [ __ ] thing
they need to let him in the hall of fame
they need a little because at a certain
point it's like they're in any way my
buddy said
he's not in this business but he kind of
said it he said he said steroids saved
baseball interesting because the only
thing that was going on that was
positive after that strike in o4 when
they [ __ ] over the expos and they
canceled the world series was uh cal
ripken beating lou gehrig's record and
then after that it was nothing and then
it was just like dude that was the only
year i can probably since the 1930s or
40s when people just listened to the
[ __ ] radio yeah right like people
paid attention to the dog days of summer
like the way like when him and then sosa
came out of nowhere in like june or july
and it was like oh it's great it's
the whole racial thing like who you
rooting for exactly what are you rooting
for i'm like i'm rooting for the big
redhead can i do that he looks like me
have you seen have you seen drugs have
you seen the sosa doc no it's [ __ ]
brutal they've already had it well i
think it's jeremy shap is uh
interviewing him and like shows his
white now he like bleach it looks he
looks what yeah it looks weird like
vitiligo yeah yeah oh [ __ ] yeah and uh
and he's like you you lied you're on
steroids he's like i don't know it's
like 60 minutes of him being like i
don't know what you're talking about you
know he won't admit it
blue eyes whoa
yeah dude yeah the world's a [ __ ] up
place
the world's a [ __ ] up place jesus
christ
yeah i hope he's happy you know i'm sure
he is i think god bless him yeah he's a
great player yeah i mean he was i mean
that's the thing like these guys are
hall of famers without that [ __ ] so it's
you know
no i think i always thought barry bonds
was a victim of the steroid era because
he was the guy and then everybody else
started taking roids and they passed him
he's like all right here's me on roids
he's 73. yeah and everybody's like oh
what the [ __ ]
your head is huge but they all you know
what [ __ ] baseball is they wouldn't let
like basketball and football was they
were posting [ __ ] on like instagram
youtube all that [ __ ] baseball was so
anal about sharing anything so you
couldn't get new fans i don't think
that's that [ __ ] baseball too on top
of the no more also like
bird magic dr j yeah saved the nba and
then it just became like it just so
naturally happened that the the uh the
celtics and and the lakers
just like with red aura back and was it
jerry buss back then who was the guy
that was just like i mean just every
move he made joe west jerry was it who
who was jerry was the owner wes was the
gm so west what the moves that those
guys made and and the players that they
got
and you know what it was the worst thing
for [ __ ] basketball and there's the
big what if is if len bias didn't die
and that was a guy that like would go
head-to-head with jordan in those
[ __ ] uh those acc games big east acc
games uh maryland
was he in the eight wait was maryland in
the acc back then i can't remember but
they would play each other it was just
[ __ ] unreal and all all the celtics
fans we were all psyched it was like oh
my god finally a celtic who can dunk you
know
somebody's gonna be above the rim we had
you know
you all we had chief and chief would
just [ __ ] the one leg up and [ __ ]
would throw it down like that's what we
had
and um
it's just like if that guy came in
in 87 after we had
that and if larry bird didn't blacktop
his own [ __ ] driveway what if he
didn't he's so [ __ ] up he couldn't
hire help what i didn't know that it was
no no he was funny that way like he'd be
in the olympic village for the olympics
and he left going i'm gonna pay him
[ __ ] nine dollars for a beer and like
six foot nine would just walk out of the
village yeah you know what i don't
you're going to some dive so you there's
a way like you respect it but just as a
fan
like uh
it's just like he got old overnight and
then uh kale got old overnight too with
the injuries you know yeah and we in the
what could have been and i'm not saying
we would have beat the lakers in 87 but
if we had
uh len bias just what the lakers would
have had to have done
and they're just old school guys like
what i love is uh michael cooper does
the local sports out there and his
hatred
for the celtics i love it
he [ __ ] hate it's not this thing now
where everybody hangs out and his
friends and it's just like well i can't
beat you what if i join your team next
year right and it's like like a foregone
conclusion some of these things or you
at least know who's gonna be in the
finals
uh like all those [ __ ] pistons that i
hated i love that they all stuck
together like i [ __ ] hated bill nye
beer i love the guy now i mean i had him
as a guest on a sports show back in the
day that he was on and he uh first off
we had such a small budget we had to
trick him into staying for a second
episode so we just switched people out
without telling him so he stayed for
like an extra hour and was furious and
then
at one point i asked him like do you
talk to bird ever like if you see him
he's cool he's like no we're we'll never
be cool that'd be funny if he tried to
leave him you're boxing him i like you
know what he said that he had the best
response to the pistons walking off and
not you know not shaking hands when
the bulls ended he goes do you you go
back and look and regret that he's like
no those guys when we were winning that
same we weren't real champions he goes
[ __ ] them
that's the best excuse i've heard for
that but i remember him
as much as he did all that cheap [ __ ]
that [ __ ] shot from the top of the
key he hit it every [ __ ] time and he
was like 6 11. a lot of big guys didn't
have a shot from that far out yeah
because he was underneath banging back
when you could do that in that [ __ ]
safe space that they have underneath so
now everybody dunks and there's nobody
there half the people are getting out of
the [ __ ] way because they don't want
to be on instagram it was like back in
the day you had to be a [ __ ] man you
had to go into the trees and these guys
would like the lakers would i mean the
pistons had a thing one night they were
just like yeah no layups tonight and
they just sent the message in the first
quarter like i don't give a [ __ ] if i
foul out you're not gonna play for the
rest of the season it's like all right
guys let's try to work the perimeter
another good nickname uh uh andrew tony
uh was known as the boston strangler wow
before the three-point line he came out
he had the low-cut dr j converse and he
would go out there and when he got hot
dude that guy was [ __ ] unconscious
and like to this day i guess danny ainge
i mean people are playing against jordan
he goes yeah jordan you know about
andrew tony he keeps he still tells
story [ __ ] white danny ainge can't
even touch the guy and even when he was
in his face he would just like
it was just it was like uh it was like
jeter when gina when it was a big moment
you know playing the red sox like all
red sox fans it wasn't you were just
like
what's he gonna do is it gonna be a
single a double is he gonna jump on the
first pitch and pull it and hit a [ __ ]
you just knew he was gonna deliver and
uh i got a buddy of mine a yankee fan
and he was in like he sent me the uh the
doc thinking it was gonna bug me you
know that this whole five parts i'm like
i'm [ __ ] i can't wait to watch that i
go every red sox fan low-key [ __ ]
love that there's no you couldn't hate
like there's just a level of greatness
where it transcends your rivaling just
like
as much as this guy is killing us like
i'm gonna be talking about this guy when
i'm when i'm 80 and plus i love those
ones where
an athlete like him or jordan is in
control of the doc and then like the
sports writers all whine and go like
well this is just like uh you know a
fluffy it's just like dude you've been
telling his story for [ __ ] 25 i would
love to hear his version
right you know i loved hearing what how
what jordan looking back thought of the
whole thing i don't hear some [ __ ]
out-of-shape sports writer and his
perception and his little soliloquies
and metaphors i loved you shouldn't on
stephen a smith that there was a clipper
you i like steven a smith i know but the
clip is hilarious i like him too but
when you're making fun of him for he he
posted a boxing clip where he clearly
can't bother that was not good for
business yeah
it's your whole job
the worst punch than that is me
i would never never post like that would
end my comedy career
but that was uh
yeah i dude stephen a is like he's like
pro wrestling on the mic i love him too
i mean
dude that guy is literally the only
pulse left i feel like on that channel
yeah you know they want to go and go
i know it they they still have some of
the the uh
the old guys uh
that that do shows on there that i that
i i do like but like i don't know espn
kind of went the way of like mtv when
anybody stopped showing like
music and stuff they kind of lost their
way to like um
i think a lot of ways all sports did
with just allowing everybody to pile on
the same teams except like the nfl is
good nhl is good too but like basketball
and baseball i just wish they would just
get they'd find that happy medium
between the owners and players having
power and you could just sort of
you know go back back to like uh you
know just like these guys are royals
these guys are yankees these like those
royals yankee series and late 70s early
80s were [ __ ] great
and uh but i think because so many
regular fans now play fantasy
and they're always grabbing players and
[ __ ] that's just the new mindset so
i always come off as this old guy like
ah in the back of the day
this is how like [ __ ] empty my life
is i actually
i was watching uh i shouldn't say this
for lacrosse fans but i never watched
lacrosse i actually sat down and watched
this is a great [ __ ] sport
yeah yeah yeah that's tough yeah it is
it's a tough game
i said goalie how do you stop that
[ __ ] thing yeah right
flyswatter yeah
you want to see pure hatred read the
comments any time espn on instagram
posts like a women's basketball clip
that is like the most hateful people
that's like that's like a step below
isis
right you know what i mean yeah
oh that was a good catch yeah
all right you guys ever watched the
little league world series i love that
[ __ ] i love it how did you see that fat
kid he was my name so and so my favorite
play is this and i hit
dingers he's just like i [ __ ] love
this kid you gotta love a fat kid
with swagger yeah come on i also love a
sloppy baseball player yeah like a
sloppy pitcher just some guy david wells
was our guy
yeah i was just talking to jersey about
all of that all the sloppy pictures when
i was growing up and you knew they had
like all the condiments and [ __ ]
something here doing this touching here
like i loved him that guy in the yankees
had that [ __ ] there and i actually heard
that players don't mind that because
they have more control of the ball
and it's like
you know well i'd rather this guy throw
in strikes than hit me in the [ __ ]
head oh there he is that's the kick oh
this kid's adorable hi my name's alfred
at home they call me big help
[Music]
i hit diggers i mean he's either going
to the mlb or uh [ __ ] worldwide
wrestling federation
wwe it's like the sandlot remember that
the redheaded kid in the sand lot stole
the whole movie yeah i just rewatched
that
on a plane baseball movies for some
reason are like the best sports oh the
best full durham they had a run too
rookie of the year angels in the
outfield
like 10 of them yeah they also because
also it it it kind of toes the line
of like the pamphlet for this country
you know what i mean it's for hey
everybody can [ __ ] make it then it
kind of ignores all the [ __ ] ugliness
of it it's just kind of it's sort of the
santa claus version of uh
of like america it's like yeah that does
exist but there's this other [ __ ] here
so it's it's very they're very patriotic
yes type of thing uh david tells joke
little little league world series or as
i call it the pedophile super bowl
something like that
i feel like he's still the [ __ ]
greatest
i think he gets a quote in here like
every week there's always a tell line
he's the best yeah he still was uh he
invented that or or as i call it you
know the
the stingray as i call it the puerto
rican of the sea
[Laughter]
steve irwin that was his steve irwin
joke oh
that's hilarious he's still the didn't
you do something for the troops with the
tale
i probably did a long time ago i just
anytime i think i'm getting good i i
watch him and i'm like all right i have
work to do he's best yeah he's the [ __ ]
it's so pure you know it just every joke
is just [ __ ] perfect and uh
yeah i remember when i uh when i first
came to new york in like
94 95
and uh greg fitzsimmons was breaking
down the city like how to get in at the
clubs and he was really greg fitzman has
really helped me out and he was saying
uh and then as far as like the stand up
down here he goes basically every white
comic wants to be a tell every black
comic wants to be chappelle that's
that's all you need to know like those
were like the two the two guys but like
you know there was all those other guys
that were also uh
also killing it you know you've got a
crazy crazy class i might be off but
it's like
all the tough crowd and norton obviously
and then even like like todd barry mark
maron oh yeah yeah i loved all of those
guys still love all those guys and like
there was just so many uh
you know great comics and it was just
like i don't know the world was a lot
smaller than if that makes any sense
where it's just like
you were just sort of doing it and there
wasn't all of this uh i got to build a
brand right and i need to film this and
what it you know you want to shoot this
on an iphone and all that you just kind
of uh
you know you're just trying to get funny
and then it was like every once in a
while there was just these industry
showcases
and you know you'd go up there and you
know [ __ ] do your 10 minutes that was
everything yeah and the manager's like
dude we're clean we're clean let them
see the sitcom let them see the sitcom
and you'd kind of buy into that and then
you'd watch a tell go up and you'd just
be like i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then the sad part is that tell
sitting off and the wings going i'm a
[ __ ] hack
nobody's happy he really i love when he
calls you up and goes is anybody doing a
bit like
nobody's doing a bit like like he checks
out his jokes right right i was in the
car with him once you need to joke about
like uh like vagina's uh snoring and
yeah text tom papa to see if he hasn't
been like tom definitely doesn't have a
right that's a dude who definitely
doesn't have that one women are like
vibrators because it sounds like they're
listening
no he's uh
fitzsimmons is said
so he came right before you from boston
yeah he was um
as far as in boston there was uh that
group of comics was uh it was rogan
greg fitzsimmons
uh
dane uh nope dane was
dan actually started like right out of
high school so he started 90. i thought
he started in 91 but like dame was more
my generation and uh
uh who else was up there like jim allen
apollo todd parker [ __ ] robbie prince
all of that
those are like you know
all of that crew and then after that it
was uh i came up with like bobby dane
patrice
um gary gullman came like right after
that
orni
and uh no we it was a great that's a
crazy class yeah it was great and then
when we when we moved and then like and
then jersey had like florentine and uh
norton and all that and then we all just
sort of came into new york at the same
time
and um
yeah and then all of that
all of that [ __ ] happened
yeah the patrice dock
has little snippets thank god somebody
was rolling a camera back then there's a
there's a scene where they're all you
guys are all hanging on the sidewalk and
then rich voss walks up and goes what is
this a couple of middles
zero laugh
a pause and then everybody laughed at
him how about how bad that bomb and i
was like oh that's such a great little
moment that we don't feel like we have
anymore [ __ ] brutal detail it was so
stupid when i look back now i mean it's
funny but it was so stupid we didn't
write one script one sketch
all we did was try to destroy each
other's confidence it was just such like
yeah it was like a bunch of abused like
rescue dogs all put in the same with
like one pork chop there it was just
[ __ ]
yeah dude i used to [ __ ] have anxiety
going down to the cellar and i was just
thinking of everybody i'm thinking like
three [ __ ] insults forever just to
kind of get it's like okay if it comes
at me i'm gonna get it off me and i'll
send it this way and
you know but what if bobby's not there
bobby's not there i can't yeah
you know and you couldn't look at the
lineup right you can't so you had no
idea who's gonna be down there
and then the worst is when you say one
and they're like you prepared that i did
i thought i was gonna be
smarter we missed that we really missed
out on that like i i guess when i first
got in yeah i remember colin quinn and
keith like beating up on me when i was
like brand new and i was like this is
amazing this yeah you know but uh yeah
my first and somehow it became like
toxic i know this is bad and then like
you go in there now and it's just like
i don't know what it is
yeah it's not i mean i'm not i'm not
gonna romanticize like it was all
because i was comics going to me like
why do you sit down that just go down
and do your spot and if i was a
healthier person i would have been like
this isn't working for me
i'm not enjoying this like
it's like to come down here and feel
good about myself not feel worse oh my
god the amount of shirts i could never
wear again
it was just like ugh i remember one time
i think it was keith keith was getting
so trashed for what he had on he just
stood up in the middle of the pounding
and just ran out
and i remember you can't [ __ ] you
could do that i didn't know you could
leave i thought you'd just sit here
until it was over
damn i saw ted do that once he sat down
everybody made fun of his sweater and he
just got up and sat at the booth and had
dinner and i was like damn that guy's
healthy
yes
he's like this is not working for me and
i'm gonna i'm leaving this he broke up
with us right right got out of the
relationship i remember when i
auditioned at the seller the second i
sat down i didn't know these guys and
keith goes look at him look how scared
he is and i was like holy sh everyone's
laughing at me i'm like this is my
audition this is crazy and he was right
i was terrified
keith was really mean so funny but he
was good at it i know i'm [ __ ] around
he really was good at it i mean he
really had a mean laugh
oh yeah he just enjoyed crushing you
yeah
i've said this before but my first
night there my first real paid spot he
was hosting and he brought me up and he
goes ladies and gentlemen you're in for
a treat and i was in the wings like oh
[ __ ] here we go and he goes jerry
seinfeld the crowd goes ape [ __ ] he goes
i'm kidding it's it's some guy
[Laughter]
okay i went up one time down there and
it was like it was just this night
everybody showed up
it was like jerry seinfeld ray romano
chris rock and then dave chappelle jesus
and i just kept getting bumped and then
it was like me and the crowd was so
spoiled
by the time they were doing the intro
people were just looking past me going
like who is it is eddie murphy coming
out right
please welcome bill burr
i do feel like you can if you go after
them and you try really hard i think
they like it so it depends no you just
address it yeah just address the
disappointment i just went on stage i'm
like that's right [ __ ] this is
what you paid for
welcome back to reality yeah well i
remember finally i think it was uh rock
chappelle and then me and i and
once they're done going like that's
their bathroom break they just saw a
show sure then once they sit back down
they're it's house money like this is
their vacation yeah they're okay with it
yeah that's true
i uh took a girl on a date once to the
seller and it was one of those nights
where all these people jon stewart pops
in trevor no all these people and she
just it was her first time there and she
thought that's how it was
and then i brought her again and she was
like ugh this was brutal it's just like
you and some other guy yeah that's not
if the first time you go down there like
that happens like
yeah
i just want people in the crowd by the
time they brought the third one up i
mean godfrey was hosting and he was just
like all right we got a special guest
you might recognize this guy from
everybody loves raymond please welcome
ray romano
and the next one's like okay this next
guy you might recognize from the
seinfeld show please welcome jerry
this next guy you might recognize from
the chris rock show please welcome chris
rock
this next guy you might recognize from
the chappelle show please welcome dave
chappelle
and then it was just like this next
guy's name is bill burr
he's been on vh1
and it's a good time to take a [ __ ]
well hey i mean i know you got to go i
uh no no i don't have to go oh okay
[ __ ] is that a mitch heideberger joke
by the way what's that uh you might
recognize me more from the store from
[Laughter]
there's another guy jesus christ did you
know him well
no i didn't but i remember um
the first time i saw him
the guy that went on before him
was just like he was running the room
and he was in this room got hot
and he just it totally went to his ego
and he just wasn't funny and he was
hateable one of those people just people
hate as he was like patricia said guys
like that they walked before they even
talked they as they're walking to the
stage they're already bombing yeah i was
like he was
i've had that he talked about this guy
in boston like that he hit me guys
always had me cry and laughing it's just
like he's just seen his like they hated
him before they even saw him
and i knew exactly what he was talking
because we've all been that guy of
course oh i was just thinking about that
he uh
i don't know it's just like those
are those those those moments where like
uh
you know when you're that guy because
we've all been that guy you have to you
have to uh
you have to figure your way out of it oh
my god the sleepless nights i just going
home to my walk through bedroom and just
laying there with my eyes open going
like [ __ ]
yeah they hated me they [ __ ] hated me
and um
but the only good thing was like new
york you got up like the next night it's
like get back on the bike and shake it
off and then you have a good set and
you're like okay good i still know how
to do it that's the only way yeah
because you start thinking like did i
forget right how to do this to have i
just hit us like a [ __ ] brick wall
and it's just not gonna go
yeah any better than this like there was
just so many of those uh
uh it's just so many of those i had two
in a row with the seller on sunday that
were not good and i was kind of like wow
it's rare that you get back-to-back new
stuff yeah but i'm i'm in the mcdougall
room that i go around the corner of you
i was like man i did kind of bad on both
of them
and uh and you're like [ __ ] i gotta wait
till monday ah yeah you know and that's
not long but we get spoiled with the
stage time you know yeah yeah and then
you start doing that thing where you
look at yourself like what is it about
me that they hate maybe i could change
something about me like my outfit or my
delivery my face
but it's just give it up for yourselves
i hate when people say thank you for
supporting live comedy i don't know why
that bugs me but it really bugs me
because it's false sincerity yeah yeah
the worst one someone's bombing he goes
i like you guys
obviously hates them
you guys are fun yeah
you guys are fun as brutal there was
comics that i saw they said that every
set
in the same place no matter how it was
going so it'd be funny and you just go
he's gonna say you guys are fun and i
know he's not having fun you just watch
the guy up there just like looking like
he's got a [ __ ] pancreas he's just
like you guys are fun
and like that's one of those things
where you would get
so teased like i used to end my sets you
guys i had a blast you guys were a blast
and i remember saying that i said it for
like years and nobody ever gave me [ __ ]
and then keith [ __ ] mean ass keith
was standing at stand-up new york and he
just goes he's yelled of course he yells
across the room he's like really
did you really have a blast and i was
like oh
jeez i was like no
i haven't had a blasted stage for months
ah and i never said it again
yeah i
i had a couple reality checks at [ __ ]
uh
uh
st stand up uh new york like that i
remember saying to dave i was going yeah
they're really tough they don't want to
they don't want to go with you and he
just went up with like the edgiest [ __ ]
ever
and then he goes
hey when he looked at me he goes how do
you feel now bill like a coward
something like that damn and
yeah and but he was teaching me like a
lesson and i just feel like nowadays
someone would just go to twitter and be
like and he said that and he had a
position of power right
it's like no he's [ __ ] throwing you
in the deep end yeah tell you to stop
being such a [ __ ] it's like you need
that yeah yeah i mean i used to open for
dave and we i remember he'd bring me on
stage at the end of the shows and like
forced me to riff with him and i'm like
i'm not equipped to riff with david tell
you know but he was just it was like him
being like let me help you let me try to
make you more comfortable yeah and let's
let's go up here and have fun and yeah
and he's like helping you to get better
like well like it's such a rare thing
when somebody is uh
as good as he is that like he also has
like uh he gives a [ __ ] about other
comics and stuff he's like it's funny
you watch his act it's like so dark and
everything but he's like one of the
biggest hearted guys you're ever gonna
meet like like
and like after jesus christ i've known
him almost 30 years i've never heard one
[ __ ] bad thing about him ever yeah
that's true i mean every comedy club
goes tonight he'll get arrested
he just jinxed him he's sexy i remember
the new york times wrote a piece on him
that was i think was cinnamon wrote this
like really flattering piece on dave
saying he's like the best club comic and
i said dave like they're so cool and he
goes this is when it all comes crashing
down like this is they build you up to
just he's like they're going to kill me
he's waiting he's not the greatest club
comic he's the greatest comp there's no
yeah i agree to like clarify that for
sure but there was something magical
about dave and like an intimate like
smaller venue because like he's so
[ __ ] quick you know not the best no
yeah his crowd work it just his jokes
his crowd work whatever whatever it's
just he's just standing there
yeah standing there talking killing i
know the best is when he's kind of he
doesn't like him and he gets angry and
he's still killing but angrily and he's
doing that thing where he slams the
microphone base oh it's the best stand
uh i mean one time he was doing jokes
and they find they just weren't getting
them and all the comics would die and
laughing and then he just did one of his
lighter ones
you know what he does let me do a little
palette cleanser here and then he just
does a lighter joke and the crowd laughs
and as they're laughing he just goes ha
ha
yeah and the crowd kind of got it he's
saying oh he thinks we're simplistic
babies and they kind of upped their game
yeah went along with like the rest of
his because they were kind of noticed
the comics were laughing and they
weren't you know and it's just like
you know even even a crowd will get like
low self-esteem all right we need to be
better we're good right we need to
[ __ ] step up our uh our comedy
listening here yeah i was telling
telling you once uh he did a joke and he
was murdering and one joke got like a b
laugh sort of an a and he looked at me
and goes we'll be right back
but it's the funniest thing i would also
pull the mic saying go this is the funny
lever
i remember it it was my birthday one
night at the seller i was just like
smoking a cigar in the steps with mike
vekione and dave comes out of nowhere
and he goes you had a good set but it
wasn't that good
mcmahon
i saw him one time riffin on this asian
woman sitting in the crowd and just
built this whole backstory he goes are
you up there he's with your adoptive
parents in connecticut and he goes
communicating through your cello
oh my god dude she died laughing yeah
back when you could like just [ __ ] i
don't know that wasn't like it was just
considered uh
like it's still considered funny but
it's just weird every once in a while
there's like the you know that person
trying to get on page six of course
about their
audience experience but as you said like
he's got the rep of being a great guy on
top of it like comics would not stand
for people coming for dave you know
no no no there's no way yeah no you hope
because he's a good dude and he's a
genius never under
underestimate show business and
self-preservation exactly look at louie
i you know it's a whole bunch of other
people who got like uh you know
dragged under with something i mean one
guy i'm just i don't name names because
i just want to get it going again but
like you know
one person just went on a date and tried
to get laid i mean it's not illegal it
also just became this incident i know i
know i was just like what the f like
what are we even doing here it's sad and
that person's the good guy yeah the
person who wrote that
we're talking about bill cosby yeah yeah
[Laughter]
we got to get him on the wall
[Laughter]
38 charges my question where's the 39
i need 39 before i i'm convinced
some people are you can't defend yeah
i've heard people defend cosby really
i've been i was on one podcast and the
guy's like
let's be i'm like
no because i gotta be honest with you
dude when that [ __ ] came out like i you
know
you know i was in the writers room on a
show and like even one of the writers
wife had a story about him trying
insisting like was at the buzzer telling
her to come down and she just had this
gut feeling it was like no and he was
screaming at her through the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
it is weird when it's like the cleanest
comic of course the most evil [ __ ]
that's why i love that eddie murphy joke
he did on snl who would have thought all
these years later
cosby would be in jail and i would be
america's dad
that's amazing
well i think the thing america hates the
most is a is a phony like when ellen is
dancing and [ __ ] and then it comes out
that she's the biggest coos ever people
are like oh okay we're live is she i
don't i'm not saying she is but i mean
dude the grind of doing that show and
having to be happy and one time you i
always looked at it like one time she
just couldn't do it anymore so she just
went out and started dancing and it was
just really an expression of how [ __ ]
sick she was of doing the [ __ ] show
and then it blew up and then she had to
do it and i was just like oh no i always
root for a comedian and you know ellen
no i don't but i think she's a great
comic and and all of that [ __ ] like
she's great yeah like
and the pressure of [ __ ] doing that
every [ __ ] day yeah after a while you
don't want to look at people you don't
want to talk
i remember working with this this older
guy on something recently and we were
just talking about everybody complaining
and he'd been in the business forever he
goes dude my first 30 years in this
business all people did was yell at each
other yeah that's all it was you just
like trying to shoot something and all
this [ __ ] that can go wrong people lose
their tempers and they just say [ __ ] and
you just gotta like roll with it
like a little bit i had a i had uh dude
i i did a movie one time when this
[ __ ] guy
the scene wasn't working and they had to
shut it down and it cost him money and i
was the low man in the totem pole so i
got yelled at he was right in my grill
like he was [ __ ] arguing a call and
he was just dropping all these f-bombs
and i was like what the [ __ ] is what is
this right and i was all like i don't
need to do [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] doing
stand-up i don't need to [ __ ] be here
but my my but i was just i was smart i
was just like this guy
is like if if i flip out here
like his story is going around hollywood
his version not mine and i just didn't
right so and then like a couple years
later the guy called me out of the blue
and stuck me in a movie
and then i hung out with them and now i
love the guy absolutely love the guy it
was just like he had a bad [ __ ] day
he had a bad [ __ ] day we've all had
it and it's just like
nowadays like something like that if
that person was to do that to the wrong
person
um all of a sudden it becomes like this
one moment yeah one moment your worst
[ __ ] moment you lost your temper you
said something that you you regret yeah
like because the next day he apologized
and he apologized in an old school way
he kind of came up we read the scene and
it worked he was standing next to me and
he just gave me a couple taps on the
shoulder and i was just like all right
that's it yeah and i'm just like and it
was it was and i was like all right
yeah i mean i'm gonna get mad at
somebody for losing their temper
it's not a healthy way to apologize but
i guess it is like the thing it was it
was because i don't want a heartfelt
apology
i really don't that's actually weirder i
will never get comfortable with that
true i will just fast forward i get it i
get it all right all right thanks sam
yeah i would just do that like all right
yeah yeah i i don't want to see you be
like you know that uh i really beat
myself up over and it's just like dude
this is worse than you yelling at me
yeah can you just yell at me again yeah
well if i get yelled at like that my
self-esteem is so bad that i'm like oh i
gotta i gotta step it up or maybe i did
something i put it on me somehow
i got yelled at by a big comic i'm not
gonna say who and i was like oh i [ __ ]
up but everybody was like he's so mean
i'm like nah i [ __ ] up dude that's
what fixed that that i did a bit on uh
that lesbian bumping into me the first
night i did it of course i didn't
realize i popped in a show of course
it's the the gay show i had no idea
probably all the dicks that they had on
the stage
should have let me know
and uh which i always think is funny on
the gay show they're trying to be like
can you stop like turning us into like
cartoons or whatever and then they do
that in a show look at all these dances
but i always then after a while i was
just like well isn't this like them just
being like
you do this
you know the whole time i was growing up
every beer commercial might as well just
had a big [ __ ]
[ __ ] in your face the whole like the
whole hetero thing was just so out there
yeah and all these movies like nine and
a half weeks and all that like that's
why uh uh oh my god uh uh billy uh
billy in the street what uh
eichner dude he's got a movie coming out
it's a gay romantic comedy which has
never been done and i was reading about
it and just what he was talking about
i'm like this is gonna be [ __ ] this
is gonna change
in a good way it's really gonna change
things and uh and i i think all of that
stuff is really cool i was watching the
trailer for it and it looks good and i
remember being like dude he's [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] hilarious he's quick but i
remember his [ __ ] out on the street is
someone like
him tom green oh you met tom green when
he had that guy holding that [ __ ]
light and the guy doesn't want to do it
anymore he goes no no no no no he put
towards the ground he goes no no no no
no no and the guy just kept like he
didn't want to do it every time he could
no
come
back
and the guy was just he just kept doing
it
and he did what it was like one of my
favorite things i ever saw on mtv was
him getting that guy to hold this stupid
[ __ ] thing you know he just stopped
this guy in new york the guy had
somewhere to go and he just got him to
hold this stupid light and like and he
put the pressure of the whole project on
him and the guy had like this this
[ __ ] up sense of responsibility like i
have to hold this [ __ ] play
that show was innovative that was that
was like big for us oh yeah tom green is
a [ __ ] beast huge freddie got
fingered as one of the most
underappreciated comedies that's a
really funny movie there's a lot of
there's a lot of those out there like
the ones that uh slip through the cracks
and all that it's usually not the one
that wins the award like you know yeah
like the gruber or something magruber's
great oh my god that's a great movie
that movie is [ __ ]
it's i will suck your dick
i'll get that clip
i will let you [ __ ] me
just tell me what you want me to [ __ ]
i just like dude that movie is just like
[ __ ]
yeah those are all like to me like if if
if if i'm watching that by myself on the
road like you know that's like that's
like the highest
like if if somebody makes a comedy in
hollywood and comedians are watching it
on the [ __ ] road and like quoting it
and stuff like and everybody was quoting
that movie i remember neil brennan went
to the table read for that he goes i've
never been to a table read that killed
as hard as that like it was just it just
[ __ ]
murdered wow murdered oh my god the
kristen wood
sex scene he's like
[Laughter]
that's one of the best comedies ever
it's crazy yeah i've never laughed and
the show is [ __ ] amazing on peacock
is do you ever do you ever see a comedy
so funny that you're like i gotta change
how i am it's a horrible way to think
but i saw mullany once at a
skirball center and it was so good i
didn't know much about him it was like
his first special and i was like i got
to be more like that which obviously i i
didn't but first time i saw that guy he
featured for me at zany's in chicago in
that little walk-in closet i love that
club oh yeah i've never seen a guy like
his the first time i saw him i was like
this guy looks like he's been like a
broadcaster like he looked like he could
host the letterman show like his first
half hour
you know there was a few guys that i saw
that were like
no-brainers yeah uh dane was one like
the the [ __ ] that he gets through the
level that that guy was killing
do he put the fear in garden guys that
have been doing it for 20 years i mean
we used to do dick dougherty rest his
soul
his his comedy clubs and all like you
know drake it mass and all these places
and dane would have the headliner like
pacing in the back
yeah he was killing that hard and he
would be like uh you know i shouldn't
have to follow that did this
my
there's no jokes here it's like well
listen to the crowd there's something
going on here right and like he doesn't
get credit he kind of came up with like
a new genre sort of style
like of it and uh you know it's just a
weird it's a weird [ __ ] business man
it is some people it's like the bo
burnham thing some people figure out not
only did he figure out a new way of
doing comedy he did the myspace [ __ ] too
i mean he was so happy that guy is a
total [ __ ] trailblazer what i love
is all the [ __ ] he got in the beginning
he just shut everybody down and he
totally delivers and then in the end you
find out this guy's a monster [ __ ]
talent oh yeah that can kind of kind of
do everything yeah in front and and
behind he he made some other movie uh i
forget the name of it years ago
about like
like teenage kids in your first date
eighth grade oh my god it was a [ __ ] i
never saw that that was great great
movie yeah great [ __ ] movie you just
it just totally put you back
into like your first crushes and the
dumb [ __ ] like he had like the kid has
like a date he's like trying to comb his
hair and
you know the dumb [ __ ] that you did when
you were a kid
and um
i saw that with my wife and like that
like and i just remember thinking like
that's his first i think that was his
first movie yeah it was like i mean this
is this is incredible he's a talent he's
a talented son of a [ __ ]
six eight
he almost hadn't played larry bird and
uh no way in that uh showtime [ __ ]
well they have another kid playing it uh
the kid is playing it's good yeah yeah
but it's not yeah i thought it was gonna
be him did you see how they filmed that
lakers one like the fast breaks
yeah they showed this guy dude the guy
comes skating in on rollerblades and
he's got a camera and then he does like
this this curl around like that and then
flips around going backwards and he's
flying down the court and the actors
playing i think magic is coming up the
court and he totally he came down
backwards and went like right underneath
the net as he like you know the whole
fast break i was just like holy like who
like who thought
to shoot like that and then what's the
odds you got a cameraman that could
skate like those kids in central park
and then when they would set up the
cones yeah yeah and they would do that
[ __ ] with their feet you know going in
and out and then they get like i would
they'd always hit like
one cone and then they'd be like
that's the damage
like it ended their whole [ __ ] day
it's like it's not enough everybody's
watching this and you can't this is this
is the 90s everybody rollerblading was
still cool oh yeah yeah and they would
always catch like one and then they'd be
like
[Laughter]
like like like just like they just lost
their shot to go the olympics right
right
seeing those clips i'm like thinking
like man the pressure to make this layup
so you don't [ __ ] up a take with
everything someone's you know doing like
he's doing what he's doing is harder
than what they're doing it's about
winning time yeah yeah yeah i can tell
you a couple i got to do it off camera
because i can't say the name
uh
you know when you get an actor who's in
a sports movie but you know is not
athletic
yeah and there's a crowd of extras
watching going like
this is going to be some movie magic
i do have to get out of here though
thank you so much the special is amazing
man i'm such [ __ ] huge fans
of you guys and your generation so keep
doing whatever you guys are doing
because you're [ __ ] killing it so
thank you thank you for saying the same
for you bill i mean the new special is
amazing it's great i don't feel all this
i'm just buzzing so much after that root
beer float
i'll trash you later when i come down
off the sugar
no it's amazing i can't wait to see your
movie too man oh yeah yeah yeah that's
what i'm in town for we got a screening
at uh
seven
in front of 200 regular people but we
got you know everybody's you know been
really helping me you know killer editor
and editors that we've had working on
this thing so
you know we're kind of getting
almost to the fun part where it's like
locked and then it's just gonna be color
and music
uh
the music is [ __ ] hard man jesus
christ that's [ __ ] hard so i got help
with that thank god
so we shall see old dads it's coming out
at some point all right all right thank
you for having me thank you thank you
bill killed it good to see you okay
thanks gang dude that was a great one oh
great he had he had to run but yeah that
was one for the books nice to get him in
here man that was a that was a bucket
list uh get yeah i mean i as you know i
texted him and i heard nothing for
i don't know a week and a half and then
out of the blue
today i'm like ah [ __ ] all right
and i even said uh you know
he's like i have a heart out of five and
i say hey come in at three we'll do
three to five he's like three to four
it's like all right three to five it i
just wanted some wiggle room but he was
like three to four and i'm like you got
it
great app great app well where are you
gonna be i'm gonna be all over special
september first yeah let's check that
out but i'll be uh when does this come
out oh uh yeah i'll be in la the 17th of
the 18th uh the bourbon room
pittsburgh improv the following weekend
uh
burlington vermont september 1st through
3rd
dania beach september 8th through 10th
louisville kentucky the following week
and then irvine the improv uh omaha
nebraska getting there from l.a is going
to be a real [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm gonna
have to fly out a day early killing me
with the lax one of the worst airports
in the planet it really is it should be
how does la not have a good airport i
know if you can get out of burbank go
for that there's no options i gotta
leave a day early in like at like 11.
yeah it's terrible and it's that's wild
yeah one of the worst things in my life
uh
phoenix arizona that'll be great i love
phoenix lexington new brunswick okc you
can go to my website for more
samurail.com shows mark what you got man
hey hey i'm gonna try to go off memory
san antonio this weekend at lol comedy
club breakfast tacos oh yeah good call
comedy connection in providence
uh we're adding shows richmond funny
bone west palm beach
improv keep going
uh or the aura at portland maine once
sold out one is getting there brandon
amphitheater in brandon mississippi with
bert kreischer
uh red rocks tumbler brewing company in
bakersfield california doing two shows
there brea improv san jose improv
the dent music hall in toronto or
danforth sorry royal oak with jeff
ausmus he's opening the roxy he's a
killer killer in a pittsburgh the
anglert in iowa city pantages
in minneapolis lincoln nebraska portland
oregon seattle vancouver new orleans new
haven boston
philly and
that's it for the year and uh bodega cat
is either out maybe we'll add something
at the beginning of this [ __ ] but like
it should it's here this month we'll
figure it out but yeah i'm pumped man
right now it's like lance bass and oh
nine almost out but not there yet
or maybe it is who knows was he not out
of no nine i don't think he was i
remember was like gay question mark was
the cover of the time magazine god it
must have been tough yeah
so all those women screaming for you i
know i know oh sick sorry i was off by a
couple my gaydar was off i'm gay
all right that's your expression
i got it from here he's my cousin
we're gonna talk to his lawyers that's
marx yeah yeah right what the hell next
is going to say praise allah
well thanks for listening guys subscribe
merch we might be drunkpod.com
email us at uh we might be drunk pod
gmail.com we got uh all kinds of [ __ ]
right yeah patreon yeah stuff on the
patreon we love you thanks for listening
[Music]
i've had a little too much
[Music]
[Music]
and naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we
might be
true
[Music]